Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill burn his time for the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
uh,
June 30 2016 what's going on?
How the fuck are you?
Um,
I'm hanging out here Sunday night.
There's 30.2 seconds left and game six and up
blurry.
Absolute mericle out there on the ice world.
We have a lake placid sequel.
I'm going to go out on a limb and say that the fucking Pittsburgh Penguins are
going to win their fifth cup.
Is this the fifth one
that's fucking realize how successful that is?
They've only been around since 67 that Brian's been around forever.
We only got six.
You mother fuckers.
Congratulations to the Pittsburgh Penguins,
man.
That's fucking great.
And uh,
really happy.
Fulfill Castle.
I,
there's actually a good one for me as a Bruins fan because Joe Thornton was a,
you know,
another former Bruins.
Either way.
I was going to say,
and I'd like both those fucking players,
you know,
I mean because of,
for the Phil Kessel Trade to Toronto,
we want a cup.
Granted,
we then traded everybody the fuck away,
but we did want a cup.
You know,
so I can say some shit to fucking Montreal fence.
Finally,
20 seconds to go.
19.
I'll tell you this.
Jeffrey's Trofeo fucker professional sports.
MMM.
Okay.
This gotta be one of the most,
what the fuck was that icing?
The goalie played it.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
What does this,
the fucking NBA,
um,
by the way,
I kind of,
I guess I understand now why it's not as physical in the NBA.
I actually looked up some of the rules.
The uh,
obviously the three second rule and isn't even as like an offensive player.
Are you allowed to be that?
I don't know.
The one of these guys can go down the fucking lane.
Uh,
defensive player can't be in the fucking painted area for longer than three
seconds or it's an illegal defense.
He is allowed to stand there fees within arm's length of the guy that he's
garden.
So all the guys got to do is just fucking run out to the three point land and
they just clear it.
Clear the path.
Right.
And it comes the honor roll student write down the fucking Lang
like Jack Day,
his quickness.
Yeah.
He has his first step.
And the fact that there's now a fucking rule that says you can't have some giant
fucking guy standing there.
Oh look it up.
Go and crazy.
Wow.
Another one in the box.
You know something I'm not close to phobic,
but one of the worst things you want to be after winning the championship is
that person on the bottom of the fucking pile.
You know,
you literally go from like celebrating that you'll want to not even being able
to breathe.
You're like,
and you get tackled and you just like
that shit.
Do you know that there's been times before who scored big fucking touchdowns and
they tackled by the teammates.
They get like the fucking leg broken.
It's unbelievable.
Um,
anyways,
congratulations to the Pittsburgh Penguins,
uh,
and Pittsburgh.
Great,
great fucking hockey town.
I know we've had a rivalry in that thing,
but I've just been there too many times.
I've got too many friends there and uh,
congratulations to Joe Barton.
Nikki's going to be going fucking crazy right now.
Um,
if I didn't have shit to do tomorrow,
what are you going over his place and watch the game?
Um,
San Jose sharks sell man.
You know,
he never made it to the final c got over that hump and I are going to have that
bitter taste in your mouth and hopefully you'll come back and win one unless my
fucking Bruins get their shit together.
And then we fucking finally one once.
So anyways,
um,
let's get on with the podcast here.
Uh,
I had a,
yeah,
had my birthday weekend.
Wonderful birthday weekend or Billy booze bag was fucking throwing them down.
Oh,
Billy postbag was acting a clamp,
right?
And fucking Joey roses was over right.
Came over on my birthday to my house.
When I say Joey,
Yo say roses.
Um,
he came over,
fucking guy was hilarious.
He came over with like a bottle of gin,
something,
some of fucking lemon.
And then he had those,
those fucking Red Cherries that might or might not cause cancer
to Phil Kessel looks like he fucking war.
He's like works with wood.
Doesn't he like some weird guy that never married,
but he could fucking,
you know,
make a Davenport out of a fucking tree stump.
You can't hate Phil Kessel though.
How's your breath?
Pretty bad.
A,
um,
oh,
and the wonderful traditional,
the NHL is shaking of the hands,
the shell of mutual respect,
I think.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
yeah,
so I fucking went,
I went way too hard on my birthday,
you know,
cause I didn't think any,
I didn't really do anything.
I worked all fucking day.
And then I came home,
I had a chorus light and I was just like,
you know what,
it's my birthday.
I'll fucking have a scotch.
Right.
Pick up my big giant fucking cube of ice.
And I threw down to scotches and next thing you know,
fucking roses was coming over and I already had three in the fucking three in
the win column.
So,
um,
I don't really remember most,
probably the third,
last third of the fucking night.
And,
uh,
I don't know.
All I know is I got a bunch of dirty looks from my wife the next day.
So,
uh,
last night I went out again and I only had like a couple of beers and a,
and then that's it.
That's it.
I'm shutting it down again.
That's how I stay in control.
You know the thing about your livers,
you don't want to spoil it.
You know,
I've slept it around enough,
so now I give it a break.
And then just when it starts to think,
hey,
you know what?
Everything is beautiful.
I give it the old fucking right there,
Fred.
It's what I do.
Um,
I had a,
I was actually great weekend.
I didn't do any stand up either.
I got to get my fucking shit together.
So maybe doing a couple shows this week around la cause I got,
um,
I got no work,
Atlantic City in Baltimore coming up this weekend,
so I got to make sure the act is ready to go.
Nice and fucking tight there.
And uh,
but this weekend,
you know,
obviously celebrating my birthday Friday night and um,
okay,
let's see.
What did I do?
Say I went to somebody else's fucking birthday party.
So,
uh,
and that one,
that was the one that I actually didn't really drink at,
but I still felt horrible because at one point I had a tequila and after that I
had birthday cake and then I smoked a cigar.
And then my body was just like,
all right,
can we,
can we fucking pick a road here?
Which,
which,
which way is the abuse going tonight?
You know?
But uh,
I was so hung over Saturday,
I couldn't even fucking walk the 10 feet to my gym and I was,
that's when I know it's like,
all right too.
Yeah.
What are you doing?
So I shut it down.
It's over.
Put a padlock on it.
Um,
okay.
I don't know how long I'm going to go.
Okay.
I don't know.
You don't want it.
Is this,
this is actually once the fucking playoffs are over,
it's kind of easy,
but I'm also going to be starting peaky blinders,
so that might be hard if the way those fucking guys drink.
I don't understand how you watch a show.
Everybody's boozing and you don't fucking drink any alcoholics out there.
Like,
how the fuck do you watch that stuff and just be like,
well everybody else is drinking.
I feel like I'm being rude right now.
Um,
I'm thinking maybe I'm going to shut it down until I go to Europe,
but even that I can't really drink cause I got a show every fucking night.
But,
uh,
I did set myself up in,
um,
in a hotel,
uh,
on one of those dates that there's actually a,
a cigar bar right around the corner.
So I might have my one for July.
Um,
I don't know.
I feel like I'm just fucking babbling.
This is just me just trying to keep my bad habits at bay.
This is a deal.
Either I'm not drinking at all or I'm smoking too many cigars or I cut down the
cigars and I drink like a fucking lunatic.
You know what I mean?
Like I've said before,
I literally think the reason why people have kids is so they won't fucking drink
themselves to death.
Because once you fucking get yourself going in your career and you've got some
free time,
why wouldn't you?
Why wouldn't you walk over?
What are you going to fucking do?
Huh?
After that fucking horrible tragedy down there in Orlando,
which I will never fucking understand.
Lunatic religious people.
I just never understand how you get so fucked up in your head that you feel like
that's your last act on earth.
Okay.
That's the last thing you're going to do.
And you think that you're going to go somewhere good.
That there's somebody after this.
If there is somebody after this that judged you,
that he's going to be sitting there going like,
all right,
wait a go.
They again,
that was the right thing to do.
Make millions of people sad.
You know?
It's just,
just the fucking worst thing ever.
And I'm,
I'm actually going to take a break here from TV,
probably four other than sports.
It's a great thing about sports is you can get away from that stuff because,
uh,
I can't handle when something like this happens.
How quickly,
Oh God,
is he getting booed?
Is he getting
booed?
Uh,
you know,
it
pluff acid every fucking year.
This is the funniest shit ever in hockey.
Every fucking year.
The commissioner of the League comes out and he just gets fucking,
I don't know why he's still getting booed.
Let's see this here.
Hang on a second.
Steve Summers,
slave Somers,
route those words and now it's,
and on the side of the Stanley Cup lab,
rub my balls on it right before it,
one of the greatest job,
he's an old spoiling at Mario Lemieux looking sharp.
He's got his anchorman sport coat on.
Tom Burton,
Tom Bergin,
he fucking the fuck's his name.
Oh,
we read comes.
Wow.
He's complimenting him.
This is one of the loudest buildings I've ever heard that Bo and them,
his children must cry every fucking year.
So anyways,
back to the tragedy.
Sorry.
Um,
I can't handle whenever something like that fucking happens.
And then you got to sit there and listen to all of these fucking people trying
to shoe horn their agendas in there.
They're uh,
you know,
the fucking theories.
And then somehow it always becomes Democrat,
liberal,
fucking conservative,
Republican,
Muslim,
Christian fucking gun control the NRA and all that shit.
And you know,
it's fucking,
it's so stupid.
You know what's funny?
If you look at the Daily News in New York City,
right,
are anti gun,
which you know,
if that's what you want to be,
that's what you want to be.
But if you anti gun and you really want
that to work,
wouldn't you?
Uh,
you need,
what you need to do is persuade the other side to come over.
Their headline is thanks a lot NRA or some stupid shit like that.
All that does is just get people's fucking backup.
All I'm saying,
it's just going to be a bunch of people screaming and yelling
is going to be a couple of actors and actresses that are going to say something
stupid.
Right?
I don't know what,
but you know,
we're always good to do something like people in the fucking people who forget
that they're a dancing monkey and think that they could solve the country's
problems
for the fucking life.
For me.
I mean,
I know I fucking talk about the ship,
but I never tried to offer solutions.
You know,
they will mind.
I tell Dick and shit jokes and fucking strip malls.
Um,
but I,
I gotta tell you though,
I just wish people out of respect for the amount of fucking paint that was just
inflicted on,
I can't even imagine what that number 50 people,
how many people right now,
I just never going to be the same.
You would think that people could go 24 fucking hours.
Okay.
Without making it about their cause and screaming and yelling as much as they're
trying to fucking help.
Can you just kinda about just,
you know,
can you go 20 fucking minutes before we got to listen to the people saying that
it's Obama's fault and fucking this and that and everything.
You know what?
I don't know whose fault.
It's nobody's fault.
You know what it is,
dude,
unfortunately we're fucking,
we're animals.
That's what it is.
Most of us are decent enough not to do that,
but it's just a,
what are you going to do?
It's just fucking horrible.
Why would I talk about this shit?
You know,
why?
Cause it's cause.
Why?
How could he not?
How do you not?
Um,
anyways,
so Sidney Crosby,
he got the MVP,
got that little shiny house with the fucking,
I dunno,
disco hat on top of it.
All right.
When's he given it to Phil Kessel.
Who's he handed off to first?
Who's he headed off to first?
Well,
a greater ratios of all sports,
so I'll tell you ways.
Fucking 9,000 bugs till you put it over your head and it feels like a baby.
You're worried about dropping?
Yeah.
Be here.
All the stories about the Stanley Cup,
all the fucking,
I can't believe they drink out of that thing every year the amount of fucking
stripper asked that has been sitting in that big people pissing in it and all
kinds of shit,
Lisa and ends up with a bottom of a pool a couple of times.
You get some chlorine.
Now I'm exposing myself to the fact I don't know who anybody is on the fucking
penguins.
All righty.
He handled it.
He just handed the cup to not Phil Kessel,
not Phil Kessel,
not Phil Kessel holding it up,
holding it up,
turning,
spinning.
What number is he?
Number six,
not Phil Kessel.
Jesus Christ.
He should have fucking skated around a little more daily.
Dude,
I would fucking take off at that thing.
I swear to God,
if I ever get paid,
we got to do that thing.
Be like when,
what's his face?
Uh,
it's one of his fucking shots at the end of his practice,
speaking of which Jesus Christ,
I was hoping for at least at least a fucking six game series with the Cavaliers.
I may guess that's not going to happen.
Right?
Um,
anyways,
let's plow ahead here with the podcast.
I'll stop watching.
I gotta keep this on until at least I would get to watch Kessel.
Oh,
he's the fucking cup here.
Huh?
The woodworker here.
Um,
anyways,
you know what I watched this,
uh,
sports this morning is I watched the,
the Formula One race,
the one up in Montreal,
kind of getting into that sport.
You know,
cause I never know what to do once hockey and basketball ends,
you know,
what am I going to read?
God knows I'm not going to fucking do that.
Right.
Um,
I'm just filibustering hey,
can you just finally get the thing that Phil Kessel already for fuck sakes.
I Dunno if he's been waiting that long.
Come on.
Okay,
you got to give it to Phil.
He's fucking adorable.
Hey,
here we go.
Phil Castle,
fill castle.
Nope.
So I'm assistant captain.
Oh,
Jesus said smoking.
I didn't recognize him with a hat on.
Yeah,
he's not one of those guys who's fucking mustache and beard doesn't connect.
You know Jesus,
he's got a terrible patchy fucking,
I dunno what now what he's got going on there.
Okay.
That's really the thing.
People can either,
you know,
you know what's the worst is the fucking neck beard,
all those people.
It fucking,
it starts off far right by the ear and then it just fucking goes,
does a nosedive.
And you guys like the Chin strap goes right up and under and they got like five
hairs in their upper lip and he's just like,
well,
what are you doing?
You know,
Tang has it now.
All right,
this has to be excruciatingly boring.
I'm going to hit pause here until Phil Kessel gets it.
Okay.
And of course they cut it off before he fucking hoist the thing cause they had a
cut immediately to gets you championship tee shirts and fucking hats.
All right,
I'll,
I'll find a fucking clip of it.
Um,
all right.
With that,
I'm gonna shut the TV off so I can actually focus here.
Um,
yeah,
so shutting down the booze.
Okay.
But if I can shut down the booze,
hit my little fucking gym out there,
you know what I mean?
Get myself a fucking man sports bra and fucking get after it.
You know,
not smoked cigars.
I will be the most in shape and board I've ever fucking been.
Um,
I got it correct.
A couple of things from the last podcast I did on Thursday.
Uh,
John,
Sally is not dead.
I meant to say Anthony Mason.
I Dunno.
I was half a fucking sleeper.
Right.
And uh,
so I want to thank all you can't on Twitter too,
that like you,
you will,
you couldn't just write to me.
Hey Bill.
John Salley isn't dead.
You had to put at John Sally so he could have potentially saw it.
Why the fuck would you do that to you know why?
Because you're fucking bored.
That's why.
Well,
hoping some fucking Twitter dust up.
What happened?
I guess I just don't understand this whole fucking generation a Yolo Douche is,
they're all about filming people get them in trouble,
Hashtag and shit add and people on stuff.
Just trying to constantly cause these fucking fights.
It's unbelievable dance.
You go outside and pick up a stick and pay cowboys and Indians like we used to
get to walk around with your fucking iPad and your,
your go pro.
Oh Shit.
I got a Gopro for my birthday.
I'm such a hypocrite.
Um,
I wanted to get one of those things and uh,
you know,
I might,
I'm toying with the idea of doing that show the how long can he go,
which is basically me pulling out of the driveway of my house.
And then you see how long I can go without snapping on people.
Um,
but I just don't want to make myself look like a fucking lunatic,
you know,
cause I feel like I've built up a great reputation for being even killed on this
podcast.
Um,
all right,
let's do it.
Let's do a little fucking
advertising reads here for the week where they allow,
all right,
right here.
Okay.
MVMT watches everybody.
When you're in your early twenties and thirties,
money can be tight.
If you're not careful,
dressing well can quickly drain your bank account.
Like spending 400 to 500 bucks in a department store.
Watch there's some brands out there charging insane prices for watches then
aren't even worth it.
Well,
if you want to look great when you go out,
but still have enough money to buy him or heard a drink,
check out the movement.
Him or her a drink.
Oh God.
This feminist agenda kicks up.
Is that happening out there?
You're really gone on a date and she buys the fucking drink.
Is that,
is that what's happening?
Is that why Bruce became Caitlyn?
He was so much of a man.
He goes,
ah,
oh,
by a drinks by whole life.
Nobody's buying me a drink.
I'm going to become a way.
All right,
check out movement.
watches.com.
Um,
I've seen them before and these watches are sharp.
Why did they fucking do that?
Stop saying that.
I've seen shit.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I fucking hate that when people do that,
just just give me the spiel and I'll read it.
Stop saying that I did things that I didn't do clearly.
All right.
Actually they did send me some watches.
I'm sorry.
MVMT.
You're right.
I did see them.
Oh,
Jesus.
All right.
Originally founded by two broke college kids movement watches.
Cut out the middle.
Well,
if you are broke,
how the fuck did you start the company?
This doesn't add up.
All right.
Movement watches cut out the middle man and they're a big brand retail markups.
In order to give you a stylish watch for an affordable price move in watches.
Start at just 95 bucks.
I'll watch with department store quality for a fraction of the price.
They're sleek and minimalistic and a modern twist on a classic style.
A modern twist on a classic style movement has grown organically purely by
supporters like you.
They started at a farmer's market right next to the all organic corn.
So join there more than 1 million social media followers and get a movement.
Watch today,
today,
today.
Go to M v Empty Michael,
Victor,
Michael,
Tom,
watches.com/ [inaudible] and they'll give you 15% off your entire purchase.
That's MVMT watches.com/bar.
All right,
blue apron.
Everybody.
Don't you wish you knew how to cook but you didn't have to shop and they just
gave you all the directions on how to do it.
Well,
thank God somebody does all blue apron.
Blue Apron knows that when you cook with incredible ingredients,
you make incredible meals unless you fuck it up.
So they set the highest believing I bought some great cuts of meat in my time
and I Christ yet cut that shit out of it.
Um,
so they sent the highest quality.
They set the highest quality standards for their community of artisanal
suppliers.
Now Jesus and what's that?
Some hipster slaughter and a fucking pig using some tool he bought off Ebay,
that some asshole made in 1870 family run farms,
fisheries and ranchers.
Whether it's Japanese ramen noodles,
wild caught Alaskan salmon or heirloom tomatoes.
Blue Apron is bringing you the best for less than $10 per meal.
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes along with pre portioned ingredients to
make delicious home cooked meals.
Additional copy points featured as desired,
or does that mean I don't have to read these?
Um,
all right,
we'll do one of them easy.
Each meal comes with step by step,
easy to follow recipe card,
pre-portioned ingredients and can be prepared in 40 minutes.
It's flexible.
Customers customize your recipes each week based on your preferences and a new
recipes or created each week by blue apron.
Since this is phenomenal,
I wish they had this one.
I wish younger.
Uh,
check out this week's menu and get two meals for free with free shipping by
going to blue apron.com/ [inaudible] you will love how good it feels and tastes
to create incredible home cooked meals with blue apron.
So don't wait.
That's blue apron.com/bird blue apron.
A better way to cook,
but that's a good way to lose weight too.
Um,
all right.
Hey,
maybe I'll lay off the booze and start doing Blue Apron,
huh?
All right.
stamps.com everybody mailing and shipping are a routine part of your business.
Um,
important.
Keeps your operations going.
I swear to God that that was sort of a sentence.
Important.
Keeps your operation going.
Dot Dot,
dot.
Hang on.
What's up,
Nia?
What are we doing?
I want to be a Taco man.
You make a tacos.
What are you making
tacos.
But I mean,
is it going to be anything special?
Excuse me?
What do you mean anything special,
Kamaya?
Before he started yelling at me.
I mean like when you make the tacos tonight,
you're going to add a little little Nini in there.
He just going to fucking do it by the box.
I'm doing it by the box cause yeah,
I mean it's just tacos.
What do you,
what would be different?
I don't know.
You always look in the fridge and you go,
Oh,
you know what?
I'll feel good.
I didn't know we had bacon.
I'll throw that in there.
Well,
you know what I,
there is a little something different.
I take that back.
I did throw something in there that might be a little unexpected
when we return.
What have you done?
What do you mean?
What am I done?
Don't fucking talk to me like that.
How far in are you on this thing and then none of your goddamn business.
23 minutes.
Oh,
Jesus.
Bill.
So this is going to go on for another hour.
Well,
yeah,
that's what I do.
I'm talking to somebody talking about right now.
I'm talking about stamps.com oh,
have you talked about zip?
No,
I haven't.
They're not on today.
No,
they're not.
I to finish this.
All right,
well time it up.
Why are you going to like,
like when you make them,
remember Fred Flintstone used to come home?
Well mom coming through the door and she had to have the Bronto Burger ready.
It's ready right now.
What?
What are you looking for?
What
my John Dacre what?
You know what kills me?
Somebody sent me a tweet and said dead on the opiate thing show in 2005 11 years
ago.
They showed me that come up.
Somebody sent me that too and they,
I had absolutely no recollection of that.
How would I forget that?
Because it was 2005 it was a long time ago.
I know,
but this is like that.
That's,
I still remember,
you know late.
We're late,
Charlie.
Bit My finger.
We're not late.
I feel like,
oh,
all these fucking assholes.
Look you.
Just so you didn't know.
It's like,
yeah,
I haven't had time to see everything on the Internet.
You fucking asshole.
That's so stupid.
I don't know.
The more I'm on this,
I like just talking into the abyss.
I got to stop fucking reading Twitter.
I fucking hate people.
You are truly addicted to Twitter.
No,
just my phone.
I'm not doing that either.
I was looking today,
I was looking up off Formula One drivers.
I watched to Formula One races in a row.
Now I need to know everything about this sport.
You're so rain man like that though.
You like,
that's what you like to do.
Get to know everything.
Got to find out everything.
Yeah.
And I get it all in there and then I forget it and then I move on to something
else.
And that's probably why I fucking forgot that that video.
Do you know there's a red bull team in Formula One and I'm just sitting,
I don't know that because I've just seen people wearing their jackets and
jumpsuits and it's on the side of cars.
How did you not see it?
If I know this?
Well,
I was thinking,
well there's,
there was a Mercedes team and then there was the Ferrari team and then there was
like red bull.
I'm like,
they were fucking drink.
So I was like,
well who made their engine?
Who paid,
who made the car?
And then they said it was,
they said it was tag hoyer.
Renault.
It's like tag or is a fucking watch?
Well,
when I type in who makes you fucking engines?
I don't want to hear about the watch people.
Maybe you should leave out the fucking part
all to shea.
I didn't know that.
That's how you get into tag hoyer.
But no,
red bull is a huge brand.
So of course they sponsor stuff like this.
No,
but they was saying,
you know the Ferrari,
the Mercedes,
and then they would never say kind of fucking,
they never said the Renault.
It's a French company making the fucking engine and I think it's a British team
and then they're talking about a fucking energy drink where the other has got to
be like Mercedes,
Ferrari and you get to be like,
yeah man.
Of course those guys are like,
they've been doing it forever and all of a sudden red bull shows up.
The Yolo Douche is a fucking Formula One and they don't even tell me who makes
their engine.
I mean that used to be like a big fucking thing back in the day.
The reason why you want it was your proven you the best car company and then
everybody's like,
well shit,
Ferrari won the last five.
I'm going to buy a Ferrari.
We're not everybody people could afford it because I'm still confused.
What's your problem with Red Bull?
I didn't.
I didn't like how I look.
I want to know who's making that engine that's went in the fucking race.
I don't give a fuck about the drink.
Okay,
so you're haven't been able to figure out who makes the engine in this one
particular race car?
No,
I had to look it up.
Okay.
This fucking young punk kid was not letting the guy won the first three or four
get past them to get into fourth place and the guy got in patient and I knew we
was gonna cause that's what I would've done.
And I knew we was a little bit older.
I'm like,
oh he doesn't have time for this kid.
And he fucking tried to go around the right and then he locked up the brakes and
he spun out and he fucked himself out of like two spots on the last lap and
everybody in the crowd went,
oh,
it's exciting.
So at the end of the day you got the information that you wanted.
It was just the fact that red bull was in there or annoyed by it.
It's really hard to follow you sometimes.
Like what?
Okay.
Mercedes is a maker of cars.
Yes.
Yeah.
So when I know it's the Mercedes team,
I know that the engineers,
the mechanics wouldn't fuck you.
Call them that.
That's their car.
Okay.
When they talk about the Ferrari team,
I know that that's their car.
I know who built the fucking thing.
When you say red bull who build the red bull car,
it's harder to figure out,
hey you want to his,
oh my God,
what the fuck?
What the fuck?
I already forgot.
Are you onto another topic already know cause that just Miami high or was it
just reminded me of a drink.
What my dad called grey goose one time he goes,
hey bill egos.
He was still drinking that Blue Swan.
You know what a does occur to me.
That's where you get it from.
That's where you get all that stuff.
The last days of Dracula,
two whores in a pool,
you know that we're the bitch go.
You get that from him.
Like you guys have a vague idea of what it is that you're,
when I'm doing the movie thing,
so you're just like throwing out like let's signifiers like you know that there
is the,
there is a girl and she's being slutty and there was a pool.
So yeah,
two horses and the pool.
It's a vampire and they're doing some sort of an interview.
So it's,
yeah,
the last days of Dracula,
like it's just,
well I know I'm doing a more like the $10,000 pyramid.
Like I'm throwing out clues for the listener and then they just go,
what you mean?
Then I go,
yeah,
I mean that because if I don't do that,
I'm going to sit there going,
ah,
and I'm not going to remember.
And the thing would be tortured.
So it becomes like a
game,
you know what I mean?
I wonder how you would do on that pyramid show cause you know they're bringing
it back.
I would do horrible on that show.
We just give them,
if I was giving you,
let's glue ever,
right when you,
all right,
you know what?
Let's play right now.
I'm going to get a fucking word and we're going to,
we're going to play right now and I'll see if I can guess what it is based on
your right.
All right,
we'll do the couple of these.
Get out of here.
Get you.
You got to get a microphone.
Go get a mic in front of when I'm finished reading this fucking advertising
here.
Jesus Christ,
they started this like 20 minutes ago.
Hey guys,
you remember way back in the day when I was talking about stamps.com.
Guess what?
They're still in business.
Yes,
she had dinner.
Uh,
important.
keeps your operations going.
I swear to God,
that's still a sentence.
But if you're making constant trips to the post office,
that's the routine you need to change.
There's a much more convenient way@stamps.com stamps.com brings all of the
services of the post office right to your desk by and print official US postage.
Oh,
I just realized you guys need to know what the fucking words are so you can play
at home.
All right?
The word's going to be,
uh,
okay.
It's going to be Paris.
MMM.
Something else in Twat.
I got to have something filthy in that.
Twats going to be the last one.
Okay.
All right.
Paris.
MMM.
Kardashians.
And um,
what else?
God,
what the fuck else?
It's why I was,
why I would suck at it.
I can't,
I certainly couldn't create the fucking show.
Paris,
go dashing Twat.
I need some before Twat.
MMM.
Pimples.
She'll get that one.
I got to give her an easy one.
All right,
let's get back to stamps.com everybody buy and print official us postage using
your own computer and printer,
print postage for any letter,
any package,
any class of male.
Then just hand your mail to the mail carrier.
You'll never waste valuable time going to the post office again so you can focus
on what really yeah
matters,
right?
Bang of that.
Brian,
the computer fucking next year,
uh,
growing your business.
I mean,
you stamps.
I use stamps.com anytime I'm a fucking,
you know,
a selling posters at the end of my shows,
send them out.
Go out there.
Um,
I'm dumb.
You know,
if I can figure out how to use it.
So could you,
uh,
right now,
sign up for stamps.com.
Use My last name,
birth for this special offer.
A four week trial plus $110 bonus offer,
including postage and a digital scale.
Uh,
don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypebirdthatstamps.com enter burr.
Alright,
thank God that's over.
So I'm not,
I'm not,
that's not one of my strong suits.
Um,
all right.
How many minutes are we up to here?
32 32.
What she gonna do?
She's still not back with the fucking microphone and he had sent the closet.
Good gravy.
Um,
all right.
We got,
well,
we got letters this week.
We got somebody from Poland.
Um,
so some fucking musicians going to tell me there's no guitar on Chameleon.
Of course.
Somebody just go,
oh,
actually that's not a good Toro to fucking xylophone.
All right,
whatever.
How'd your band do?
How's your band?
All right.
And she's back.
Oh,
you know what?
I'm just gonna hit pause so we can stop torturing people here.
I love the pause button now.
Okay.
And we're back everybody.
All right.
Once again,
it's tied to
the fuck it $10,000 pair amid.
All right.
Nia Europe first,
will you be giving or receiving a,
I will be receiving what they said.
Be given a taken.
Yeah,
I don't,
they think giving a response.
I don't fucking as something like that.
I don't see me given the password or there I'd taken the fucking
clues.
Um,
all right.
Gun to your head if you had to give a take.
All right.
Okay.
Ready?
I'm ready.
Are we on the clock here?
Hey,
guess add the tension.
Can we get a clock in?
Clock timer here?
I'm going to get one of these on youtube right now.
No,
we don't need to do that.
All right,
here we go.
Use the stopwatch thing on the computer or the people at home.
The fans at home.
I'm going to hear a fucking clock going.
All right.
Okay.
We're back.
And uh,
there's only 33 seconds on this clock.
So there's four things you got to get.
Okay.
Is there a topic or um,
no,
there's nothing.
This is just random shit that came out of my head.
I,
you got,
you got 33 seconds.
Let's see how many you can get.
Okay.
All right.
You Ready?
Ready?
And here we go.
Okay.
She's a city.
It's,
uh,
one of the great cities in the world and people love it and they talk down to
you.
They fucking hate you.
Oh,
you smell get out of my country.
You stupid American.
What?
You're a stupid American.
I'm better than you.
You like my baret Harris.
Yeah.
Um,
oh my God.
Stick it in my twired.
I'm going to marry a wrapper.
Hey,
my dad doesn't,
he has his dick,
but he's a woman now.
Kim Kardashian,
uh,
Kris Jenner,
we got,
oh,
I wonder what they're doing.
Keeping up with the cardiac.
Yes.
You got a,
you got to,
you want to keep playing.
Your clues are horrific.
Shut up.
Stick this up.
Much wine
girl now,
but he's still has his dick.
It's true.
It's all true.
Everything.
I pick this up,
White Swat and that.
What's supposed to be a clue.
I was thinking she did a porno.
All right,
let's do,
uh,
let's,
we got two more.
Alright,
here we go.
You Ready?
Yeah.
Got Precedent.
This just fun.
All right.
Here we go.
You Ready?
Okay.
Uh,
nearly be a UV taking or receiving.
Giving or receiving.
What is fucking is receiving.
Okay,
here we go.
It's like you saying that.
All right.
Here we go.
Starting in three,
two.
All right.
Uh,
the,
well,
while we're misunderstood,
uh,
I didn't bite that mailman.
He looked at me first pimple.
Yes.
Um,
all right.
This is a,
this is something that you say and people get mad and they can smell sometimes,
but if it's a fresh one,
it's great and you,
you fucking stick it.
You stick it right.
It's between your legs.
Keep going.
It was the worst name.
Worst name,
cons worth.
Now that is bad.
Yes.
Woo.
You did it.
It did.
It did it.
Oh,
that was great.
That was great.
Be asked to be on the route egg pyramid show.
That will never happen.
That come on to be like,
come on.
So can you,
that's a real show you give you yeah.
You to take work away from me.
Oh,
come on.
Um,
I will never be on a charades team with you.
Oh,
come on.
I will never,
I got to come up with some and,
and do you,
well,
why don't you do it?
Why don't you fucking come up with some and then I'll do it.
How about that?
All right.
Didn't you just say that?
Yes.
All right.
I want it.
Wait,
what?
No,
I got it.
We'll do it on Thursday.
Okay.
We'll do one on Thursday.
All right.
You come up with the gut.
We got the quick little timer there.
I know.
Stick it up.
My twat.
Actually,
I probably disqualified the last one because I used the word twice when I was
trying to get the Kardashians,
right?
Yeah.
Mary around.
Hey look,
what would you won't believe what we're doing over here?
Keeping up with the Kardashians.
It worked though.
It did work.
What do you want from me?
All right.
Coming off a bender here.
Hey,
it's a rough one.
You know.
All right.
You're talking about your birthday.
Uh,
yes I did.
I had a great time.
I,
it was a whole birthday weekend.
Yes it was.
It wasn't what I had my own little sad alcoholic one the night of mine where you
was stone sober and you watch me and Joe to Rosa just fucking,
we were having fun.
You were having fun.
That's true.
But eventually I had to leave.
Yeah.
Well you weren't partying so you know,
what are you gonna do?
Um,
and then,
you know,
last night was phenomenal also.
And then I went down to the Improv.
Ben Bailey was in town,
the Great Ben Bailey.
Yeah.
We hung out.
We had a couple of drinks.
Just fucking laugh and tell the stories and uh,
to Rosa was down and we had,
it was a great time,
you know,
and I got to go to work tomorrow,
so let me read these things in a minute.
Go.
This was fun.
I'm going to go have a Taco.
I'm all right.
I'll see you in a little bit.
Okay.
Thank you for blank.
We have a wonderful addition of our home game.
For you.
I think you got it.
I think you actually got the two right in the end.
Um,
all right,
here's somebody else.
I'm late to the party with on Youtube,
but I'm sure I'm not the only one,
right?
Isn't that a song?
I'm not the,
I'm not the only one with mixed emotions.
Um,
you guys seen this kid that just,
it's,
it's fucking hilarious.
I feel bad cause he's,
he's got some sort of issue,
but like he just,
he just fucking goes around and he tells people this,
this Charlie,
uh,
is it Zell enough?
He just fucking goes into gyms and tells people that he's the greatest.
And he goes,
let's spar and they have no fucking clue.
You know,
he just goes in and he fights in accounting and the cow and just kind of puts
his gloves on and this kid swings for the fences and fucking knocks out an
accountant and turns around and could see that one punch,
knock down an accountant deck.
And he's like,
that guy was a marine.
He talked to all the shit.
He actually started calling up professional fighters.
And I was surprised that some of them actually took time out of their day to
fight the guy.
And uh,
I mean at some of the most compelling shit I've ever seen a,
granted they have like 74,000 hits,
219,000 hits,
105,000 hits.
So once again,
I'm sure you're just finding out about it now.
Yes.
Yes I am.
Have you watched the youtube video that it just shows how the fucking
differential works out the fuck.
Did you miss that?
Oh,
that's right.
Cause you don't have time to watch all of it.
All right.
So if you get a chance,
watch this kid.
Uh,
Charlie's Zellen off.
Um,
oh my God,
he's got the flip phone and he just calls.
This guy keeps calling this guy a fucking clown.
I don't know a lot about like people's like names and shit,
but I will say this about the kid.
He's got the fucking balls to go in there,
man.
I wouldn't do that.
Anybody can call up a professional boxer.
It talks shit.
But to actually show up for the fucking match.
Um,
I dunno,
he fought like he flood fuck Floyd Mayweather senior
and then he was losing.
So he stepped out of the,
uh,
stepped out of the fucking ring and then step back in and tried to sucker punch
the guy and then somebody jumped in like bare knuckle,
beat him down.
It was just,
it's insane.
Anyway,
she got it.
You got to watch it.
Charlie's Zellen off.
I'll spell it.
I'll spell it for you.
I hope he doesn't get hurt and I hope he doesn't hurt anybody.
And uh,
but he's,
he talks shit like,
who's that fucking will forte character.
Um,
Calhoun.
What the fuck was his first name?
We will forte
Calhoun.
Tim Calhoon.
Um,
Tim Calvin,
I,
Tim Yellen think that we should sell the statue of Liberty.
He talks shit like that.
He's on the phone going,
you're fucking clown.
I'm gonna come down there.
I'm the greatest of all time.
Even been duck me for years.
You fucking clown.
And he never raises it up.
It's like,
it's some of the best shit talk.
And I've heard just as far as like a unique style.
So I got to give it up for that.
But it's definitely a,
some of the more bizarre shit that you're gonna Watch.
Um,
which of course sent me down a rabbit hole of watching people fight.
And I saw the bus driver that throws the upper cut at that girl who's fucking
screaming at him.
And A,
I know you're not supposed to hit a woman,
but in defense of him,
he led with an uppercut.
And I watched what happened when Buster Douglas did that.
So in a way I thought that that was a gentleman he move before he grabbed her by
her hair and threw her off the bus.
I know the things that I find entertaining.
I know I'm out of my mind.
All right.
Poland,
everybody.
I got,
I got a letter from Poland.
Hey you freckled face fucker.
Why I want you to come to Poland is beautiful and we have great alcohol.
Um,
I would love to go there.
You know what the fuck I live on cause I live on the other side of the world.
And you're the first guy that's asked me to go there.
Maybe I've had like maybe three emails.
I'll go there.
I'll stand there in front of five year Charles Bronson.
Look a motherfuckers,
I'll stand over there in front of you.
You know,
I don't give a shit or do you got nice beaches up north and there's a nice town
down south.
I Dunno about Warsaw.
I don't know what's going on there.
You guys still have horses in your army of you fucking updated.
Just Shit.
You know you can get still.
They live next to Germany.
You know,
you've got to watch out for those cuts.
I was,
that was a cheap shot.
All right,
it's beautiful.
And we have alcohol.
All right,
just a question.
When will you come to the fucking Saudi or to the fucking Saudi Arabia or Dubai
or Kuwait?
Um,
I dunno when they like us,
I'm not going over there and getting kidnapped and get my head sawed off on
fucking youtube aids.
Bill Berg just checking in on you and they fucking,
you know,
you'd have to,
you'd have to say something.
No you couldn't because they need to worry that they do something even worse to
you.
I wait to write it as they got through the juggler.
Oh Man.
I would find,
yeah,
do a quick little filly set on,
uh,
just say everything that would piss him off,
which I would say what I know,
you know what I would be,
I'd be rocking and crying.
I'd be,
I'd be a bitch.
How the fuck do you just sit there waiting for them?
You saw your fucking head off.
Like I know that doesn't happen in Saudi Arabia,
but you know,
if you steal something in Saudi Arabia,
they chop your fucking arm off.
You know,
I don't need that pressure,
you know,
I don't fucking need that.
Some,
we just could just throw something stolen in your bag because they stole it.
Next thing you know,
I'm going to Chop Chop Square right?
Granted,
I don't know shit about any of these countries.
All I know is that we've,
we've thrown enough rocks at the beehive over there.
I don't feel like going over there and getting stung.
It said,
right.
Do by,
yeah.
I'd love to go to Dubai where they got a full,
they got slave labor that built the whole fucking thing and they confiscated
their passports and the number one cause of death with him,
his suicide.
I can't go there and support that shit dead.
Oh,
fucking city.
It looks like,
uh,
like the Kardashians designed it.
It's beyond fucking cheesy.
We've got the tallest building in the word Delia,
Kuwait.
I got no problem with that.
Saudi Arabia scares me.
Dubai,
when you start paying the people that build the skyscrapers,
I'll go there.
And,
uh,
Kuwait,
you know,
I don't know.
I mean,
you guys should kind of like us,
right?
We helped you out in the early nineties.
Well then we,
I dunno,
I have no idea that part of the world scares me.
I've connected in Dubai when I was coming back from Mumbai,
India.
But I just hear all these horrible stories that they promise all these people,
um,
in Asia that you're going to come over there,
there's all these jobs,
you're going to make all this money and then they come over and they confiscate
their passports and they don't let them fucking leave.
And A,
they see no way out and they killed themselves.
I don't know if that's true.
I don't know if it was that or if that was at Walmart.
I forget.
All right.
Hey,
Billy funk face.
There's no guitar in that Herbie Hancock Album,
the bass player,
the bass is played by Herbie on a synth and Paul Jackson,
the basis,
uh,
plays the guitar line on the Higher Register.
The base I never fucking knew that.
Love the podcast and stand up.
Let's jam some,
see that I made funny.
And then what did you do?
Your taught me something.
Um,
all right.
X men and sexism.
Hey B is for bill.
I haven't seen the billboard Rose McGowan is upset about,
and I agree with your assessment on the situation,
but I think you miss characterize the effect of displays of male dominance over
women.
I mischaracterized it.
Is that a word?
Um,
it's not that someone sees a picture of a man choking out a woman that thinks
it's okay and then goes and does it himself rather.
It's like a piece of a puzzle.
It's just one of these fucking agenda people.
Again,
a guy sees a picture of a man choking out a woman.
Then he sees a picture of a man yelling at a woman.
Then he sees a picture of a woman being backhanded by a man.
You get the point,
you see how they do this.
You see how he just led me across the fucking river to his side?
Like I'm that fucking stupid.
No,
I don't get your point.
This is what I understand.
A kid fucking sees his parents.
Okay?
If the dad beats the shit out of his mom his entire fucking childhood,
I understand that.
He'll either not do it or totally fucking do it.
But this whole fucking thing that you see images and then you do shit.
Okay.
I watched the fucking racing car was red bull on it all day today.
I,
there's no fucking way I will ever drink.
It.
Certainly would not put it in with some vodka ever.
I have no desire to ever drink that fucking drink.
Uh,
human beings are way more fucking complex.
Then the,
uh,
the,
the cartoon version,
you know what I mean?
Like when,
when people have meltdowns and people film it and then like,
you know,
people would just,
oh,
he did that then therefore he is that.
It's just people are way more complex than that and you don't just see a picture
of this and then see somebody yelling at this person and blah,
blah blah.
Oh,
that's all it,
it just takes billboards and TV shows and then all of,
all of the way that I was raised goes out the window.
I can tell you this,
sir.
All right.
With your little fucking Fisher price fucking point here that you're making is
when I was a kid,
the amount of violent fucking movies I watched all the Friday the 13th I watched
all the fucking a nightmare on elm street's.
I watched all the Halloween's Halloween three one of the worst fucking movies,
our season of the witch.
I watched all of those things.
I saw scar face when I was like,
what the fuck?
Although 15 I saw all of that shit.
Okay,
and I can tell you this,
I never went out and killed somebody.
So explain that to me.
I never hit a woman.
I never did any of that,
so,
okay.
I just,
it's,
I don't agree with that.
I,
having said that,
I agreed with them saying that,
you know,
you could,
could've picked a better picture.
You know what I mean?
I just looked at the picture.
I was like,
I don't want,
I don't want to see when we get choked.
I don't want to see that,
you know?
I don't want to look at that.
Fast forward to where she breaks out of the choke.
Hold that.
I'd like to see that.
Um,
anyway,
so let's continue on with this.
You get the point.
Yeah,
I fucking,
I,
I can't,
I can't stand people.
All right.
After a while,
the man sees the overall picture that our culture condones dominance over women.
It's a piece of the larger cultural trend.
This is literally paint by numbers like this is,
this is all the shit that you see on TV.
This type of thing happened a lot in old movies.
Just watch any Humphrey Bogart movie movies can play a huge part in reinforcing
gender inequality and Co in a culture.
Can I ask you a question dude?
Or a lady?
Whoever the fuck this is itchy.
Do you ever see anything else in movies?
Okay.
Do you just see what the man does to the woman?
So what about now all these other movies,
you know,
so then I guess you would then agree that the latest Mad Max was an anti man
movie because I didn't see the movie.
But evidently the Mad Max guy doesn't do anything and the woman takes the
reigns.
So judging that this is the way that you view x men,
then you must certainly see that the last mad max was obviously
okay.
You know,
uh,
whatever.
Reverse misogynistic,
what is that fucking word for it?
But someone who hates men,
I always forget it because it's never used.
It's never brought up.
It's just called being a strong woman.
Hatred of men.
Misandry I even if I'm saying it right,
am I s a n.
D.
R.
Y.
Um,
do you do see it as that?
I just don't think people are that simple.
I really believe that when someone is a little kid,
okay,
if they're a little kid and they're in your house and you're their parents,
I really believe that whole thing that your words become their thoughts 100% I
don't believe that people like you're with your kid every fucking day of your
kid's life up until when?
I don't know the first time they go away for the first 10,
12 years before they ship them off to camp.
Or even if you don't do that,
you could basically be with them almost every fucking day of their life.
For the first 15 years of their life.
Okay.
And you're telling me that movie,
billboards and movies and that type of shit will undo
all of your parenting?
Yeah,
I can look,
I can see some shit that you'll see a movie and it makes you want to go out and
fucking,
you know,
play cowboys and Indians like we did.
You know?
But I never really went out and fucking
killed anybody.
Right.
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't agree with that.
I don't know.
I understand that the images are bad and that type of shit.
I definitely get all of that.
But the fact I can't make that leap that then it's all floating around in my
head.
And next thing you know,
I punched my wife in the face and it's not because I'm a bad guy and had a bad
father.
It's because I saw too many movie billboards in scenes in movies.
I teach this to make,
to give movies that level of fucking power.
I,
you know,
I don't know.
You want to fucking make me go get a beer?
Okay.
I'll go buy a candy bar.
But I just don't see myself,
you know,
upper cut and some old lady in the food line because I saw the wrong movie.
Fucking billboard.
I,
I disagree with you.
Agree to disagree sir.
Or ma'am.
Alright.
Fiance's parents are evil.
Um,
but I can't do anything about.
All right.
Uh,
so I'm getting married this month.
Super excited to marry the love of my life.
Congratulations by the whole experience.
But the whole experience is going to be awkward and weird because their parents
don't like me.
Uh,
in fact they hate me.
Oh,
Jesus.
Uh,
I'll not give you the whole what is,
she comes from money and you're done.
You're fucking Billy Joel.
You marry an uptown girl.
Huh?
You singing it in your garage?
Uh,
let's see.
I'll not give you the whole convoluted story,
but the upshot is that they're conservative upper class,
highly successful Latin American business types.
While I'm in Australia and middle class left the arts graduate.
I knew they came from money.
Anyway,
we've been together for almost a decade now.
And even though I know they've said horrible things about me behind my back and
tried to talk her into leaving me numerous times,
they've always been pleasant to my face.
Oh,
that's even worse.
That said,
there were a few years there where they didn't talk to either of us after we
told them we wouldn't baptize the hypothetic or children.
We still don't have.
Okay.
Uh,
but we,
we don't mention that.
Okay,
so you guys are agnostic or something.
I don't know.
Basically,
it's going to kill me to have to look at,
at their stupid fucking heads on my wedding day.
Uh,
we only invited them out of a sense of obligation,
but now it's hitting home.
Then I'm actually going to be part of this family now.
What I need is a longterm plan of attack to survive the next few decades until
they shuffle,
shuffle off this mortal coil.
I know living a happy life with their daughter should all should be all the
revenge I need.
But if you saw her father's face,
you'd want to give him the old right there,
Fred,
to guess I need some kind of middle ground.
Any advice?
Uh,
Fanton nuts.
I don't even know what that means.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Come to Australia.
You mentioned that some sort of red nut over there.
I have no idea.
MMM.
Oh,
Joe Barnett just texted me.
Said smiling like the butcher's dog.
Um,
good for him.
All right.
Uh,
any advice,
uh,
the most important thing that you said there is that you're realizing that
you're marrying into this family and,
uh,
that is something that you never really fucking think about enough.
I don't think enough people do until you got,
Yup.
Just picture,
this person is going to hold your child someday and want to take the kid to a
ball game.
MMM.
You know,
or whatever.
So there's,
there,
there is that,
but uh,
I dunno,
the only way to do it,
I w there's one way to do,
you could just try to kill the guy with kindness or he could just sit down and
look at the guy and just say,
look,
man,
whose kid?
No,
I know you don't like me.
I know you're just being polite.
A lot of,
you know,
respect for your daughter or whatever,
but you don't,
you don't have to be nice to me anymore.
You know,
we can see each other on the holidays or whatever.
Anytime you want to come off or what?
I don't say that.
Don't see,
you don't want to come over.
Uh,
Jesus,
that would drive me nuts if the guy was being phony nice to me,
I would at some point,
you know,
have to say to the guy that listened.
He didn't,
you don't,
maybe it's just say that.
Go out golfing with a guy and just say,
listen man,
I don't want to be any more of a thorn in your side than I already am.
Just know that you don't have to pretend to like,
okay,
then me just fucking walks off the first tee.
Um,
I gotta be honest with you,
dude,
I don't know what to tell these.
These are tough ones,
man.
This is really fucking,
how close do you live to them?
That's another one.
You know,
if you guys live a state away and you only see him three,
four times a year,
you can tough out a couple of weekends,
you know what I mean?
However,
if,
um,
you know,
if they live right down the fucking street,
and then they don't approve of you and then you have a kid and then they're
going to question how you bringing it up and they're already getting involved
there already.
I can tell you this,
they're already way too fucking involved.
All right?
This is the deal.
You can say whatever the fuck you want about whoever your kids dating until they
get married.
Once they get fucking married,
you've got to back off,
you know,
unless it's obviously something horrible,
the persons,
one person's abused,
abusing the other person,
but like they got it back the fuck off.
So maybe you've got to have that conversation.
Just be like,
listen,
I know you don't like me,
but I love your daughter and she loves me and we got married,
so you need to deal with that.
Yeah.
Fuck him.
Yeah,
he needed to deal with it.
We got married.
All right,
so I don't need you coming over here giving me the fucking stink face in my own
house.
All right.
You already did it.
Once you do it again,
I'm going to take your head on a stick it right in the fucking ice box.
All right.
If I fucking had enough of you.
Yeah.
Fuck this guy.
I have no good advice for this for you,
sir.
I don't know what to tell you.
I just hope it works out.
But uh,
don't take any shit from the guy.
And when it comes to you and your wife,
I would just make jokes about it.
Um,
you know,
I'd be like,
Hey,
you know,
I'm going to go hang out with your dad today.
She like,
really?
No,
he hates me.
Remember whenever,
you know,
just keep it late.
Um,
but don't joke about it too much,
cause then she'll say,
but it really bothered me,
sir.
Um,
I think you're going to be okay,
but I'm not.
I'd be lying to you for like seven if I didn't tell you that.
17% of me thinks that you're really fucking stepping into some shit here,
but you know what?
Everybody who gets married does so good luck to you.
Good luck to you,
but don't take any shit from that guy.
I think he can get to the mom.
You can get something.
You can Scharmer.
Right.
I bet you can charm her.
And once women have more forgiving,
right?
Until they're not,
and then they'll fucking kill you and you sleep.
But generally speaking,
they're fucking more forgiving.
And I think if they just,
if she really sees the love between the two year,
she could back off and then that's what you do is what you do.
You divide and conquer.
Fuck him.
All right.
I think I'm on it.
Some fuck that guy.
Make,
make her mom love you.
All right.
That's it.
And then she'll start nagging at him and he'll either go one or two ways.
He'll either given and eventually like you or to heal.
It'll fucking eat him up and will die sooner.
All right.
Jesus had to go all the way to their bill.
It didn't like it did.
All right,
last one.
Here we go.
Dating an older guy.
Oh geesh.
Hey Bill.
I'm a 22 year old female from Slovenia,
Slovenia,
modal.
Thank you for the podcast.
It makes me laugh out loud.
Uh,
which not many things can do.
That's fucking great.
I would love to go over there at some point.
Also that Eastern European tour is gonna fucking happen.
I just have to have time in my schedule.
Um,
because all of those countries I've never been to from fucking Lithuania and
fucking a story,
whatever the fuck.
And then other one is up there all the way down through Romania and backup.
All I know is,
is if I can fucking somehow get over and then see all those countries get a
bunch of different stamps on my passport,
I'm into that shit.
Plus every one of those places like Prague or something has all those art deco,
all that art deco furniture that all the places over here,
they order it from for nothing and then Jack it up over here.
What do I do?
Buy a desk over there and then ship it fucking around the world.
Like,
I'm going to save any money.
That's a stupid idea.
Anyways,
I'm 22 years of,
Oh,
okay.
I would love to hear you taking my situation.
I'm a university student and I play sports professionally here in Slovenia.
Uh,
keeping busy,
working out about eight times a week.
My first coach since I was like 12 years old,
is now my really close friend.
Oh my God,
his name is Ann Woody.
Is it?
Uh,
he's since moved on to cow coach internationally.
I almost said couch coaching internationally,
but we still keep in touch.
He knows me from when I was a little girl and he used to always tell me I was
like his younger sister,
but I,
but recently I noticed he switched his approach grouse.
He's a 35 year old single guy.
Oh my God.
The fucking red flags.
I can barely see the type here anymore.
And he only comes to Sylvania and July through August we were always able to
talk for hours,
tell failed attempts at dating to each other and generally get along better than
I have ever gotten along with anybody in my life so far.
He's always make me laugh,
complements my personality and how good I look,
but never in a creepy or disturbing way.
Okay.
All right.
My experience with guys my age was never like that.
I'm not trying to say I'm too mature for them,
but I would always compare them to him and they would mostly bore me and
connection was never there as much as it is with him.
I feel like boys my age are pushovers.
At least those I had experiences with and I feel they couldn't offer me
interrelationship more than this older guy offers me and just a friendship.
Uh,
yeah.
And also when you're 35 this guy's going to be 50 so there's also that and then
you're still going to want to go out and he's going to be ready for nap time.
So,
uh,
no that too.
And he's 35 he's almost side of the leak if you're an athlete,
you know what I mean?
35 that's when he got to start taking the illegal drug drugs,
you know,
to hang around for an extra couple seasons.
Right.
Anyways,
she says.
we are hanging out a lot during this summer and I feel more and more vibes and
attempts from him.
He takes me out to eat and drink.
He is always asking me somewhere I,
I,
I know he's putting the moves on me.
My issue is that I,
now I know we are in different stages of our lives.
I know he wants to get married and have children to fuck this guy.
Fuck this guy.
You're 22.
You got the whole life ahead of you.
When the fuck did he start hitting on you then?
Now this isn't fair.
This is like shooting fish in a barrel.
You've known him since he was,
you were 12 no,
no,
no.
Stay away from this guy.
This is how I know this guy's a creep because even I wouldn't do this.
Okay.
Fucking walk away,
sir.
Stand down.
I most certainly am not ready for anything like that.
Uh,
children,
all that shit.
She's saying,
I like to go.
I like to drink,
go out my friends getting compliments from guys all to soothe myself.
Esteem,
which is not fully developed yet.
Exactly.
I'm still finding myself and I know you will interpret this as I want to fuck
around.
No I don't,
but this is not really the case.
I actually want to find a right person and fall in love.
Well,
you're very mature for your age.
Actually.
22.
I'm dodging his attempts and usually laugh him off when he puts the moves on me.
Get away from this guy.
I don't want to read this,
this making me uncomfortable,
Yadda Yadda,
Yadda,
Yadda Yadda.
I don't give a fuck.
Fuck this shit.
Fuck this.
She said,
sorry if that was hard to read.
My English is a little rustic.
English is tremendous.
Um,
yeah.
Stay away from this guy.
All right.
Um,
I can't even,
it was,
that was so disturbing to me that I can't remember if he's still currently your
coach.
Um,
anyways,
a film.
What vibes.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
Where the fuck is this thing?
I got to find my first coach since I was 12.
He says,
move on to coats internationally,
but we still keep in touch.
All right.
I don't know when the fuck he moved on.
Uh,
but what it was he,
he,
he's,
no,
no.
Fuck that.
All right.
Listen,
this is what you got to hold on to.
Okay.
The fact that you feel the way that you do when you're 22 years old,
there is somebody out there your age that is like you.
And if it was easy to go out and find love,
everybody would find it.
All right?
But the problem is,
is you know,
you gotta,
you gotta go through a bunch of mistakes first.
All right?
So,
um,
I don't know you,
I don't know him,
but this is not the person you're going to settle down.
Don't,
don't fucking do this.
Don't do it all right?
He's got way,
way too much of a mental advantage on you at 35 and 22 and he could really
fucking hurt.
Yeah.
Um,
I say you deal with the fact that you find guys your age are not mature and,
um,
you're gonna run into somebody who is,
you sound like you're really good looking and you're into sports,
right?
You're getting these compliments when you go out.
So you probably have like these fucking,
a Yolo Douche is hitting on you,
which you need.
You know what you need.
You need a nerd.
I think you need a nerd.
Go find some fucking kid that likes to read,
you know,
so he probably has an idea to build an APP.
Whatever these fucking kids are doing,
that's what you want to do.
You know when I go fuck around with your 35 year old creepy.
He are.
I really want to get married and have kids.
Oh.
Dilia though.
Yet.
That's why you hitting on a 22 year old you piece of shit there.
Fuck that guy.
All right.
Uh,
I would uh,
yeah,
stick with people your own roughly your own h.
All right.
And that's coming from an older creep like me.
So you know,
it's good advice.
All right,
that's the podcast for this week.
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
And uh,
congratulations to a Pittsburgh penguins fans.
And you know what?
Also the San Jose Shark fans,
they know I've been there plenty of times.
Seeing the Bruins lose and finals to all those great Edmonton teams.
Um,
so my condolences,
but hey,
you actually got to the finals and you've got a great team to build on.
Um,
and that's it.
One down,
one to go,
the NBA ends.
And,
uh,
I guess I'll start watching a little bit of baseball,
but I'm,
I think I'm going to stick with the Formula One racing until I get to football
season.
We'll see what's up.
All right.
That's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
Then I'll check ed idea on Thursday.